the main thing is with a hyperbola is
that it's either gonna be opening up and
down like in the y-direction or it's
going to be opening left and right in
the x-direction and if any of this seems
confusing as I'm going through it I'll
have a link to another video I did
talking about hyperbola as it goes into
more depth but this is a particularly
challenging problem when they just give
you the asymptotes and vertices so I
want to show you how to work with this
one but the basic equation you can see
is y minus K squared minus X minus H
squared equals one and you got your a
squared and your B squared but the
important differences here are that
notice that here you've got the Y
squared is a positive term when the
hyperbola is opening in the vertical
direction in the Y direction up and down
and here you've got that x squared as
the positive term when it's opening in
the horizontal direction in the X
direction left and right and you notice
that the a squared is with that first
term of that positive term and then just
again just to refresh the distance from
the center to the vertex this point
where the hyperbola bands are turns that
distance is a the distance from the
center to the focus that distance is
called the C and the distance from the
center to right here this distance is
called B and the equation that relates
all those values together is C squared
equals a squared plus B squared just
like Pythagorean theorem so the other
thing to recognize is that when you have
these asymptotes you know the slope of a
line is the rise over the run okay so
you can see you can figure out well if I
go this much for the rise this much for
the run in this case it's going to be B
over a ok but if it was open the other
direction like so you would actually be
doing a over B so an easy way to
remember this is that you know when you
think of a slope slope is what it's the
rise over the run which is really like
the change in Y over the change in X
right and when you think about the
change in Y this number here that's
underneath the Y is gonna be your rise
okay and the number underneath the X
here is gonna be your run so for this
one it's going to be a over B for this
one the slope is actually going to be B
over a ok so it's easy to remember the
number the Y is the rise and I'm wearing
underneath the X is the run when you're
calculating the slope for your
asymptotes but let's get into this
example here so what I always like to do
is I like to draw a sketch just to see
what I'm dealing with
to help me to formulate my equation and
you can see that the vertices here that
they give a
are at 2 negative 4 1 2 3 4 so 2
negative 4 right about there and 2 12
okay so let's see 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 way up here right okay so that's
our other vertex and then the asymptotes
are at y equals two x and y equals a
negative 2x plus 8
okay first thing I want to do though is
I want to find the center point and the
center point is going to be halfway in
between those vertices so we can either
count and find the midpoint or you can
take negative 4 plus 12 okay add those
together and divide by 2 so that's going
to come out to 4 so we're really over
here at 2 comma 4 which is going to be
right there okay there's our Center 2 4
ok then from the asymptotes perspective
we've got y equals 2x so that means it's
going up 2 over 1 like this ok and so
you can see it's looking something like
like this and then for the next one y
equals negative 2x plus 8 so 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 and this one has a slope of negative 2
okay like so okay approximately right
and then we know that the hyperbola gets
closer and closer to those asymptotes so
I'm just drawing a quick sketch here for
us so we can see you know that it's
opening up and down so we know it's
opening up and down so that means that
we're gonna be looking at hyperbola in
this form it's going to be Y minus the
y-coordinate of the center squared minus
X minus the x-coordinate of the center
squared equals 1 and now what we have to
do is find these denominators we need to
find our a squared and our B squared
well remember the distance from the
center to the vertex this distance right
here is a and we can see that that is
how much well let's see that's going to
be 8 units so you can see this is the
difference between 4 and 12 so that's
going to be 8 squared which is 64 okay
so that's our a squared and we figured
out that a is equal to 8 now all we have
to do is find our B squared okay that's
this value right here and the equation
that relates all those together is C
squared equals a squared plus B squared
and we also know that the slope of this
asymptote here is going to be
the rise over the run okay so when we
think about the rise over the run we can
think about in this case a divided by B
is our slope so let's write that down
so a divided by B is equal to our slope
and we know the slope is 2 all right so
that means we're going up 2 over 1 so
that means that let's see what do we
have here we have a is equal to 2b right
and we know that a is 8 so 8 equals 2 B
divided by 2 and you can see that B is
equal to 4 but in our equation we want B
squared so this is going to be 4 squared
which is 16 and there we go that's the
equation of our hyperbola given the
asymptotes and the vertices what I like
to do is just sketch it out so I can
kind of take a look at it as I'm working
through it so I can find out you know
what I have whether have a B C that kind
of thing and if you need to again I'll
have a link to talking more about you
know what a hyperbola is and the
different forms of the hyperbola and so
forth I'll put a link for that for you
but subscribe to the channel check out
more math tutoring videos on my youtube
channel Mario's math tutoring and I look
forward to helping you in the future
videos I'll talk to you soon